room right when it was getting real
popular you hear me so I had
[__] like I was taking them in
micro doses saying like yeah Daniel was
having essentially the same effect like
I feel like a perk I had with me like on
the focus and said you see what I'm
saying yeah for sure happy focused and
my head I'm like all right I've been
micro just I'm like I'm gonna take I'm
gonna take like more than a micro dose
I'm gonna take a little chunk out of the
bag and I'm like I'm gonna play the game
and I'm sitting there and I get through
one match we'll be playing uh Call of
Duty then I get through another match
and I'm feeling [__] kick in but they
had an all the way keep them okay let me
just kick it in think about the time we
got to the third match them [__] was
on me
I'll be right back I ain't come back for
like three hours [__] I took 17 showers
[__]
I I switched my pajamas three four times
and they all got all the sheets off the
bed and [__] yeah I'm watching Hellboy
from the shower
because I can see my TV from like if I
can open the door